SECRETARY AUSTIN, AS WELL.
THIS WILL BE BROUGHT BACK UP
AGAIN AS SOON AS LUNCH IS OVER.
SENATOR TILLIS WILL ASK FOR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SID
APPLICANTS IN ROUND TWO.
JOHN.
>> John: LOOKING FORWARD TO
ROUND TWO IN 25 MINUTES.
THANKS.
SANDRA.
>> Sandra: BRING IN ANCHOR OF
THE STORY, MARTHA MacCALLUM, WE
HAVE BEEN WATCHING EVERY MINUTE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
SO FAR YOUR TAKE ON THE FIRST
BELIEVE ACCOUNTING OF THAT
AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL WATCHING
THE TOP MILITARY BRASS?
>> ALL THESE GENTLEMEN AND TOP
MILITARY ADVISORS ADVISED
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO LEAVE 2500
TROOPS ON THE GROUNGDD.
THEY DID NOT GET THEIR WISH.
GENERAL MILLEY SAID I WILL NOT
RESIGN BECAUSE MY ADVICE IS NOT
LISTENED TO, GIVING ADVICE IS
WHAT I’M HERE TO DO.
MY FATHER DIDN’T RESIGN AT IWO
JIMA AND HE STUCK TO CARRYING
OUT HIS MISSION AS HE SAW IT.
ON THREE SIGNIFICANT POINTS, IT
IS CLEAR ALL THIS TOP MILITARY
BRASS DISAGREED WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND THINGS HE’S ON THE
RECORD FOR HAVING SAID.
ONE HE SAID HE DIDN’T RECALL
EVER BEING TOLD HE SHOULD LEAVE
2500 TROOPS.
HE COULD HAVE SAID, YES, THAT
WAS ADVICE I WAS GIVEN, THAT IS
NOT THE DECISION I DECIDED TO
MAKE.
HE SAID, I DON’T RECALL ANYONE
TELLING ME THAT.
HE SAID AL QAEDA WAS GONE.
WE HEARD TODAY FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS CLOSE TO THE
SITUATION, THEY SAID AL QAEDA IS
NOT GONE AND PRESENTS A GROWING
THREAT.
THEY ALSO TOOK I THINK ISSUE
WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS
DEFINITION BY PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
SAYING IT WAS A LOGISTICAL
SUCCESS AND STRATEGIC FAILURE.
THERE IS A LOT OF DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN THE TOP MILITARY
OFFICIALS AND PRESIDENT BIDEN AS
MUCH AS THEY TRIED TO CAREFULLY
TREAD THAT GROUND.
>> Sandra: INCLUDING CHANGE
BETWEEN COTTON AND AUSTIN ON THE
INPUT MILITARY LEADERS WERE
GIVING THE PRESIDENT.
LISTEN.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN LAST MONTH IN
AN INTERVIEW WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS SAID NO MILITARY
LEADER ADVISED HIM TO LEAVE A
SMALL TROOP PRESENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> I BELIEVE THAT FIRST OF ALL,
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT TO BE AN
HONEST AND FORTHRIGHT MAN.
>> IS THAT TRUE OR NOT?
>> THEIR INPUT WAS RECEIVED BY
THE PRESIDENT AND CONSIDERED BY
THE PRESIDENCY FOR SURE.
>> EXCHANGE TO THAT.
>> THAT IS CONTRADICTION.
DID TELL HIM AND HE DID LISTEN
TO US.
THERE IS CONSEKWENS TO THE
DECISION OF NOT LEAVING PEOPLE
IN.
WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN 4000
AMERICANS AND SID’S OUT OF THE
COUNTRY, ACCELERATED THREAT WITH
ISIS-K.
THEY HAD ARGUED COULD BE
CONTAINED OR MANAGED TO GREATER
EXTENT IF WE LEFT 2500 TROOPS ON
THE GROUNGD.D.
THE CONSEKWENS ARE EVER
CHANGING.
GENERAL MILLEY SAID I WAS TAUGHT
AND RAISED TO BELIEVE AS
MILITARY MAN FOR 42 PLUS YEARS,
YOU NEVER SET A DATE CERTAIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN OWNS THOSE
DECISIONS AND CAN STAND UP FOR
THEM.  WE LEARNED TODAY IN MORE
SHARP CLARITY HOW DEEP THE
DIVISIONS WERE.
>> Sandra: HERE IS CHAIRMAN
MILLEY SAYING THE ENEMY CONTROLS
KABUL.
WATCH.
>> OUTCOMES LIKE THIS ARE NOT
DETERMINED IN THE LAST FIVE
DAYS, LAST 20 DAYS OR LAST YEAR
FOR THAT MATTER.
HOW COMES LIKE THIS, OUTCOME
THAT IS A STRATEGIC FAILURE
ISSUE THE ENEMY IS IN CHARGE IN
KABUL.
>> Sandra: THAT WE KNOW TODAY,
MARTHA, RIGHT?
>> STRATEGIC FAILURE, THE ENEMY
IS IN CHARGE IN KABUL AND WE
WATCHD THAT PLAY OUT WITH GREAT
FRUSTRATION.
IT WAS INTERESTING, I THINK
TOMMY TAUSH TUBERVILLE SAID CAN
MILITARY DEFEAT ANY FORCE ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH ESSENTIALLY?
THE ANSWER WAS YES.
THAT PUTS YOU IN SITUATION WHERE
YOU SAY WE HAD AN OPTION TO NOT
LEAVE IN CHARGE OF AFGHANISTAN,
HOW WE BROUGHT IN MORE TROOPS OR
SECURED MAINTAINED OUR PRESENCE
AT THE AIRPORT, BAGRAM AIR BASE,
A LOT OF OBVIOUS QUESTIONS YOU
CAN GO BACK AND LOOK AT.
BOTTOM LINE, MOST AMERICANS FEEL
IF WE WANTED TO, WE COULD HAVE
DEFEATED THE TALIBAN, DECISIONS
ALONG THE WAY, IT IS 20 YEARS